[Musique]
un jeudi placée sous le signe de la
contestation sociale
suivant l'appel de plusieurs syndicats
des manifestations ont eu lieu partout
en france à lyon
des centaines de personnes se sont
rassemblées pour dénoncer la casse
sociale en cours dans le service public
sur le service public
ça c'est certain c'est que c'est à dire
que mettre des intérêts privés
la rentrée des intérêts privés avec une
notion de rentabilité profile dans une
entreprise avec des missions de service
public
pour nous c'est complètement aberrant
les soigne on regrette toujours un
manque cruel de moyens matériels et
humains
alors que les services hospitaliers sont
sous pression depuis le début de la
crise du coc vide 19 la santé on a
besoin de moyens on a besoin de manu
moyens il ya un matériel on a besoin de
moyens humains et on voit que la
politique qui est menée depuis des
années n'a pas du tout été arrêté par la
crise qu vide depuis le début de la
crise qu vide on a des unités d'élite
qui continuent à fermer
on a un manque crucial dans un pays de
l'hydre animations avant on a à l'heure
actuelle
il est bien que les draps animations là
c'est exactement le chiffre qu'on avait
avant le comique se sont aussi greffé au
cortège des étudiants qui réclament un
plan d'urgence de 1 5 milliard d'euros
visant à lutter contre leur précarité la
réouverture à 50% des universités ainsi
que l' embauche de personnel éducatif
à marseille ils étaient plus d'un
millier à manifester pour faire valoir
les mêmes droits en tant de crise qu'il
faut c'est justement de l'aide à ceux
qui en ont besoin c'est pas de l'aide
aux très grandes entreprises qui de
toute façon n'en profiterons que pour
super pour le licencier des gens ou pour
continuer à aller dans le sens de la
destruction des acquis sociaux
on a vu que les factures augmenter
puisque 70 % pour le gaz puisse 30 %
pour l'électricité
on nous a fait croire et aux citoyens
que l'ouverture à la concurrence allait
faire baisser les coûts d'électricité
alors c'est pas du tout le cas
les factures ont augmenté et là le
risque maintenant c'est que les citoyens
soient dépossédés de leur outil de
production et de distribution d'énergie
l'énergie secteur hospitalier
médico-social secteur de la culture mais
aussi des retraités et des jeunes
une mobilisation hétérogène avec la même
volonté de créer une exaspération
profonde envers la politique d'austérité
menée par le gouvernement
et ce n'est pas l'entrée en vigueur de
la réforme de l'assurance chômage
annoncée pour l'été qui risquent
d'apaiser la situation